ではあの三敬...サーラーン
礼拝三宝灌頂の瞑想という感じで始めます
ではナモタッサダします 「
ナモー・タッセ・バガヴァトー・アラハト・サッマー・サムブッタссе」
「ナモー・タッセ・バガヴァトー・アラハト・サッマー・サンブッタッセ」  「
ナモー・タッセ・バガヴァトー・アラハト・サッマー・サンブッタッセ」
「仏ダン・サラナン・ガッチャーミ」
「ブッダン・サラナン・ガっちゃみ」
「ダンマン・シャランアン・ガチャーミー」
「ダンマーン・サラナン・ガッチャーミ」
「サンガン・サラナン・ガッチャーミー」
「サンガン・サルナム・ガッチャンーミ」
「ドゥティヤム・ピー・ブッダン・サラナン・ガッチャーミィ」
「ドゥティアピアピ・ブッダム・サラナム・ガッチャーミ 」
「ドゥティヤマンピー・ダンマン・サラナン・ガチャーミ」
「ドゥティヤンピー・サンガン・サラダン・ガッチャーミー」
「ディリアンピー・サンガン・サラナム・ガッチャーミー」
「 ta ti ヤンピー・ブッダメ・サラナン・ガッチャーミー」
「パティヤンピー・ブッダン・サラナム・ガッチャーミー」
「ta ti ヤンピー・ダンマリー・サラナン・ガチャミー」
「パティアンピー・ダンマン・サラナム・ガッチャーミー」
「ta ti ヤンピー・サンガン・サラナン・ガッチャーミー」
「パティアンティー・サンガン・サラナム・ガッチャーミー」
「アーナーチ・パッター・ウェーラマネー・シッカ・パタン・サマーディアミー」
「バーナーティ・パター・ヴェーラマニ・シッカーパン・サマーディアミー」
「阿梨陀多納・ヴェーラマニー・シンカー・パダン・サマーディーヤーミー」
「アリンダダーナー・ベレーマニ・シッカーパン・サマーディアミー」
「カーメス・ミッツァー・ザーラ・ヴェーラ・マニ・シッカー・パダン・サマーディアミー」
「パーメ스・ミツジャー・シャーラ・ベーラマニ・シッカーパン・サマーディアミー」
「ムーシャーワーダー・ヴェーラ・マニ・シッカー・パダン・サマーディアミー」
「ムーシャーワーダー・ヴェーラマニ・シッカーパン・サマーディアミー」
「シーラー・メライ・マジャパーマラ・ダンニャ・ヴェーラ・マニ・シッカー・パダン・サマーディアミー」
「スーラーメラヤ・ワジャーパーマラ・ダンニャ・ヴェーラマニ・シッカーパン・サマーディアミー」
サーリプッタです  サーリプッタ
では慈悲の瞑想をいたします
背筋伸ばして一緒に読んでください
[咳]私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願い事が叶いますように
私の悟りの光が洗われますように
わ-......でありますように
私は幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々が悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい人々が願い事が叶いますように
私の親しい人々にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
[silence]生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
はい ありがとうございます